der schweizer bauernverband beteiligt
sich nicht damit soforthilfefonds für
ehemalige verdingkinder und andere opfer
fürsorgerischen zwangsmassnahmen dieser
entscheide ist vor wenigen tagen
gefallen
die begründung von verbandsdirektor
jacques bourgeois lautet seine
organisation hätte diese politik von
fürsorgerischen zwangsmassnahmen nicht
beschlossen ehemalige verdingen und
heimkinder reagieren verständlicherweise
empört wieder wird die verantwortung hin
und her geschoben
aber wer ist schuld am mit der
institutionalisierten fremdplatzierung
verbundenen leiden und wie konnte es
überhaupt geschehen dass bis in die 1970
er jahre in der schweiz kinder bei
bauern verdingt oder in heimen versorgt
wurden
bundesrätin simonetta sommaruga ist
heute bei uns zu gast im gespräch mit
norbert bischoff berger nimmt sie
stellung hat bundesrätin sommaruga
wer ist schuld am schicksal am leid von
ehemaligen heimat verdient kindern die
frage der schuld ist eine ganz wichtige
frage und vielleicht eine der
schwierigsten fragen
ich spüre immer wieder das bedürfnis
nach schnellen antworten wer war
schuldig wer war schon wegen an diesem
leid ich spiele das bedürfnis das
schnell festzulegen und dann die
schuldigen zu benennen
ich denke es ist ganz wichtig dass wir
uns immer wieder bewusst sind und je
länger ich mich auch damit beschäftigen
was in dieser zeit alles geschehen ist
dass wir uns bewusst sind es gibt nicht
ein leid es gibt nicht nur die
verdingkinder es gibt tausende
zehntausende vom tragischen
lebensgeschichten von verdingkinder von
heimkindern von zwangs adoptierten und
jedes einzelne schicksale der einzelnen
lebensgeschichte zählt und das heißt für
die frage der schuld auch hier müssen
wir genau hinschauen wer war beteiligt
unmittelbar und wer hat vielleicht
weggeschaut und nicht gehandelt
und wo beginnt die schon die frage wir
sind ja hier im bundeshaus studio liegt
bei ihnen als justizministerin die
aufarbeitung dieser fälle dieser
vergangenheit dieses dunklen kapitels
der jüngeren schweizer sozialgeschichte
bis hinein in die 1970 er jahre wie sind
sie denn mit diesem thema konfrontiert
worden erstmals es war tatsächlich so
als ich aus bundesrätin ja als
justizministerin natürlich auch mit
diesen fragen konfrontiert worden bin
hat mich das auch menschlich mich
persönlich sehr berührt und ich war
erstaunt und ich denke das ist etwas
ganz wichtiges wie viele es wären nicht
wissen was in dieser zeit geschehen ist
und zwar sie haben es gesagt wir sind
die jüngste geschichte hinein
es ist ein dunkles kapitel und ich bin
überzeugt dass eine gesellschaft ein
interesse hat und ein interesse haben
muss dass wenn sie die gleichen fehler
nicht immer wieder begehen will dass sie
dann hinschauen muss und ich würde sagen
gerade was hier passiert ist mit für den
kindern aber eben es ist wichtig zu
wissen ist gab menschen die zum beispiel
jahrelang im gefängnis waren ohne eine
straftat begangen zu haben ist
zwangssterilisationen es gab menschen
die gezwungen wurden ihr kind zur
adoption freizugeben
als erstes zu wissen was ist alles
passiert und ich habe manchmal den
eindruck das ist wie eine landschaft die
noch nicht kartografiert ist und ich
finde es eine der wichtigsten aufgaben
jetzt dass wir hinschauen dass wir
wissen was damals passiert das was
geschehen ist
um auch daraus unsere lehren zu ziehen
weil wir sind heute nicht gefeit davor
die gleichen fehler zu machen
sie spannen den gesamten bogen unseres
gesprächs ich höre aus dass sie
beruflich mit diesen fragen konfrontiert
wurden
sie haben sicher von einzelfällen auf
höhe gehört aber wenn ich richtig gehört
habe sagen sie als justizsystem bin ich
konfrontiert worden mit all diesen
fällen
was haben sie gedacht wie sie die
dimension dann langsamer rahmen von
10.000 möglich bei hunderttausenden von
fällen im 19
bis weit hinein ins 20 und auch das war
ja ich denke eine entdeckung und ich
merke jetzt je stärker das thema ihr
hier diese lebensgeschichten jetzt
plötzlich auch bewusst werden und auch
bekannt werden in der öffentlichkeit
ich habe ganz viele leute jetzt
getroffen die gesagt haben ich kenne
auch eine ehemalige es verdient kind ich
kenne auch jemand der 20 optiert wurde
ich habe in meiner familie jemanden und
da merken wir alle glaube ich dass in
diesem land diese zeit noch sehr präsent
ist es gibt heute menschen die
schreckliche dinge erlebt haben und ich
glaube es ist immer wieder etwas was wir
uns auch bewusst werden müssen
es gibt ein unrecht dass jedem menschen
begangen wollten ist dessen dimensionen
direkt zum teil gar nicht erahnen und
deshalb müssen wir diese geschichten
kennen ich habe letzte woche ich bekomme
immer noch sehr häufig briefe einfach
die vorstellung von diesem kind dieser
erwachsene frau 81 jährig die mir
geschrieben hat und gesagt hat sie
erzählt zum ersten mal in ihrem leben
ihre geschichte ihre geschichte wo sie
zum beispiel jahrelang ein winziges
zimmer gehabt hat neben dem kohle keller
und am abend im winter musste sie mit
ihrem kinderkörper die leintücher
auftauen weil ein tische gefroren waren
das sind momente die mich auch berühren
und die mich überzeugen dass wir ein
interesse haben und auch eine
verpflichtung und eine verantwortung zu
wissen was war und gerade weil so viele
menschen betroffen sind glaube ich ist
es heute jetzt auch ein gemeinsames
bedürfnis und eine gemeinsame aufgabe
geworden und deshalb möchte ich diesen
prozess jetzt weiterführen unbedingt da
muss noch sehr sehr viel gemacht werden
ich habe diesen film der verlinkung 2011
ein neuer film ich habe diesen film
gesehen und eine ausstellung die in
zürich in einem unscheinbaren
schulhaus gezeigt wurde ich habe mir die
haare gerieten
es gibt es nicht bei uns in der schweiz
wir schauen unseren kurzen ausschnitt
aus diesen film der verdingbub
kompakt in die sache
[Musik]
das ist damit raus kann künftig erwiesen
habe zu dem buch hauptsache ist gelogen
komm geh mir deine schuhe der nummer
capo ja der anfang eines leidensweg es
kommt dann ein weiteres verdingkind wird
geschwängert auf dem hof vom sohn des
bauern wird letztlich umgebracht wie
erklären sie sich aus heutiger sicht den
umgang 1950 er jahren mit kindern in
dieser art ich weiß nicht ob man das
erklären kann man kann versuchen zu
verstehen
zum beispiel warum wurden kinder
überhaupt weg gegeben warum wurden
kinder verdient das war zum teil aus
puder wirtschaftlicher not ich habe
keine entschuldigung aber eine erklärung
es gab große familien enorme armut in
diesem land zum teil mussten die
familien dann nicht mehr wenn sie zehn
kinder hatten wie sie ihre eigenen
kinder durchbringen und sie haben ihre
kinder daneben weggegeben zum arbeiten
es gab auch behörden entscheide die
heute nicht mehr zu verstehen sind erst
in diese fürsorgerischen
zwangsmassnahmen sie haben ja all diese
fälle aufgelistet nicht nur für die
kinder auch andere zwangsadoption
zwangssterilisation da war zum beispiel
ja eine vorstellung dass eine frau die
ein uneheliches kind bekam einen
liederlichen lebenswandel führt man hat
sie unter druck gesetzt das kind zur
adoption freizugeben
man hat sich sterilisiert gleich nach
der geburt des kindes ohne sie zu fragen
man hat sie in ein gefängnis gesteckt
wegen liederlichen lebenswandel jahre
lang zum teil ohne dass es eine
möglichkeit gab eine beschwerde
einzureichen
das sind vorkommnisse die unglaubliches
leid verursacht haben und die menschen
ich denke das ist in diesem film ein
ausschnitt jetzt da wir dürfen nie
vergessen es sind hunderte sind tausende
von einzelschicksalen
jedes ist auch wieder anders aber das
sind natürlich menschen die die in ihrer
kindheit genehmigt gedemütigt wurden
erniedrigt wurden ja auch psychische
physische sexuelle gewalt erlebt haben
und damit eigentlich in ihrem ganzen
leben einen so schweren start hatten
dass sie ein leben lang das nicht mehr
aufholen konnten
es ist nicht allen so gegangen ich denke
es ist wichtig das werden wir sehen was
jetzt hier im filmausschnitt im heim
passiert ist auf dem bauernhof passiert
ist es ist wichtig dass wir hinschauen
das ist passiert und gleichzeitig aber
auch sagen es gab auch andere
situationen
ich habe ihr schicksal in diesem besuch
buch versorgt und vergessen nachgelesen
ehemalige verdingkinder erzählen
es ist wie sie sagen es gibt auch phasen
die kinder werden ja danach verschoben
wie ware versorgt und vergessen von
einem heim ins nächste bauernfamilie die
nächste es gab orte unterschiedlich wo
sie drangsaliert misshandelt worden es
gab orte wo sie gut ich sagte den
umständen entsprechend mit vielleicht
hunger aber gut gehandelt worden
das heißt man kann nicht sagen das war
der zeitgeist
nein das kann man nicht sagen da hätte
man sich das viel zu einfach machen es
gab sicher gewisse vorstellungen auch
moralische vorstellungen die anders
waren aber zu sagen damals war das
üblich damals ja hat man kinder
geschlagen heute darf man das nicht mehr
das ist falsch es ist genau welche sagen
es gab auch familien es gab auch heime
es gab auch kirchenvertreter die sehr
gut mit diesen kindern umgegangen sind
die sich bemüht haben und gleich einer
schwierigen situation das beste zu tun
es war also möglich auch anders mit
kindern umzugehen und das hat eben
beides gegeben und ich denke wir sollten
schon auch differenziert immer wieder
anschauen was war denn eigentlich
aber was war denn eigentlich dass
niemand etwas gesagt hat ich mein hier
ist ein fall involviert
die lehrerin die später im film vorkommt
meldet sich bei den behörden auch beim
fahrer
es wird nachher nur noch schlimmer für
diesen verdingbub er kriegt noch mehr
druck noch mehr schläge hier eine andere
geschichte heidi hartmann in diesem buch
wird gleich nach der geburt weg gegeben
es ist 1938 geboren kommt zu einem
reformierten pfarrers ehepaar wird eine
woche weg gesperrt weil sie etwas
geklaut haben soll es stellt sich dann
heraus eine woche im badezimmer bei
wasser und brot es stellt sich raus das
ist gar nicht gestohlen hat kaum eine
entschuldigung erst als sie als
erwachsene in die gemeinde zurückkehrte
gestand die reine ehemalige vorstand
schafft mitarbeiterin dass es alle
gewusst hätten aber niemand etwas gegen
den pfarrer habe unternehmen wollen ja
sie haben mir am anfang habe ich auf die
frage nach der schuld gestellt und ich
denke gerade diese beispiele zeigen dass
jemand der schlägt der sexuelle
physische psychische gewalt anwendet
sich als einzelner schuldig macht was
ist unbestritten es gab auch in dieser
zeit 1 strafgesetzbuch es war nicht ein
ein rechtsfreier raum aber die frage
stellt sich und derjenige der etwas
gewusst hat diejenigen die vielleicht
geahnt hat und nichts unternommen hat
weggeschaut hat eine gesellschaft die
vielleicht auch weg schaut wo ist hier
die schuld wie weit geht diese schule
ich denke das ist mit der aufarbeitung
und die wollen ja diese geschichte
dieses dunkle kapitel unserer schweizer
geschichte aufarbeiten um eben zu
schauen wo beginnt eben auch eine
mittäterschaft in dem man wegschaut in
dem man sich nicht meldet und ich glaube
da haben wir sehr viel zu tun
gerade auch weil wir heute uns auch
immer wieder fragen müssen wir schauen
wir genug in die gesetze haben sich
geändert seit 1981 gibt es eine
beschwerdemöglichkeit das hat es vorher
nicht gegeben wenn jemand zum beispiel
heimgebracht wird ihnen im gefängnis
gebracht die die gibt es heute nicht
mehr einfach die behörde die entscheiden
kann aber hinschauen aufmerksamkeiten
sensibilisiert seien zivil courage haben
und etwas ansprechen da sind ja heute
auch gefordert die schuld des staates
dass ich meinen in vielen fällen waren
ist eben zwangsmaßnahmen die
schulbehörden behörden die gehandelt
haben
ich meine schon damals war die aufgabe
der behörden für das kind zu sorgen
das war damals nicht anders als heute
also ein vormund hatte den auftrag dafür
zu sorgen dass es diesem kind dessen
form und er ist dass es diesen kind gut
geht
nun gab es natürlich überlegungen und
ich denke da stellt sich dann auch eine
schuldfrage dass man vielleicht nicht
das kindeswohl in den vordergrund
gestellt hat sondern geschaut hat dass
die fürsorge kosten für das für das
staatswesen für die gemeinde möglichst
tief sind das war ja auch ein grund
warum zum beispiel kinder zum teil
verdeckt wurden das eben als
arbeitskraft eingesetzt werden konnten
und dass das für das tagesessen haben
stickel wurde und das sind natürlich
überlegungen die dem kindeswohl häufig
nicht gerecht wurden
das ist heute an bis ich denke wir haben
heute gerade wenn es um das kindeswohl
geht gerade auch in den letzten jahren
eine professionalisierung vorgenommen
beiden kindesschutz behörden die
geschult sind die besser wissen wie man
hinschaut aber wir sind niemand von uns
ist gefeit davor dass er heute unrecht
geschieht das auch heute zu wenig
hingeschaut wird
ich sage ihnen vielleicht ein ganz
anderes beispiel aber dass das nicht
direkt mit diesem thema das zu tun aber
das thema menschenhandel und frauen
handelt
das ist auch ein blinder fleck wo man
wenn man nur herausfindet und unrecht
bekämpfen kann wenn man hinschaut und
ich denke eine gesellschaft hat diese
aufgabe hinzuschauen und das
justizministerium möchte ich dazu
beitragen dass wir eben unrecht von dem
wir wissen dass wir verhindern können
dass es
wieder geschieht mit menschenhandel
meinen sie jetzt zum beispiel
prostitution oder menschen die ihm
verkauft werden um zum beispiel in die
prostitution oder in einem haushalt zu
arbeiten und das hat gewisse
ähnlichkeiten zum thema jetzt über das
wir heute sprechen verdingkinder kinder
dienen in heime gebracht wurden
pflegekinder
es gab ende des letzten vorletzten
jahrhundert versteigerungen von kindern
hat kindern versteigert man abgeschaltet
wie ist ihre arbeitskraft wie viel
können sie einen blick und hat sie auch
ausgelesen und dann verteilt und das hat
auch damit zu tun also es gibt es heute
noch dass man heute eben frauen männer
verkauft weiterverkauft um sie dann zum
teil auch unter zwang zu gewissen
leistungen zu zwingen
auch bei uns in der schweiz das gibt es
bei uns in der schweiz und deshalb ist
es so wichtig dass wir uns immer wieder
bewusst werden eine gesellschaft kann
sich nur für besser in eine gesellschaft
kann gewisse fehler nicht mehr machen
wenn sie hinschauen und es stellt sich
schon die frage wie machen wir das
machen wir diese aufarbeitung arbeiten
und ich denke das wichtigste ist wie
machen sie zusammen mit den betroffenen
sie haben jetzt erwähnt es ist besser
geworden
es gibt jetzt berichte über es gibt eine
neue gesetzgebung kinder und
erwachsenenschutz es gibt neue behörden
diese caps da waren jetzt aber auch
viele berichte dass da vieles im argen
ist es war in der sendung club zum
beispiel oder kassensturz bei uns die
rede von chaos von überlastung von
überforderung führt dann dazu dass
zwölfjähriges mädchen von der polizei
sozusagen in den urlaub denn der vater
verlangt hat geführt wurde
ich würde sagen wir haben viel verändert
und verbessert in diesen letzten jahren
hat wirklich viel dafür getan dass zum
beispiel die aufsicht über die heime
verbessert wird das eben kindesschutz
behörden aufmerksam sind dass sie
einschreiten können das eben auch eine
gewisse professionalisierung stattfindet
viel wurde gemacht auch die gesetze
haben sich verändert das ist heute klar
lasst landschaft zum beispiel ist
professionalisiert waren ist also dieser
entwicklung und die gesamte laien mehr
die diese hier und die ganze
gesetzgebung ist stärker darauf
ausgerichtet dass wir heute sagen wenn
der staat eine aufgabe hat dann ist es
die schwächsten glieder seiner
gesellschaft zu schützen und das sind
jetzt zum beispiel häufig kinder oder
menschen die abhängig sind aufgrund zum
beispiel eine behinderung da schaut man
heute besser hin
aber ob das im alltag passiert und das
dann wirklich auch gemacht und gelebt
wird das ist eine frage des hinschauens
auch heute noch das ist eine frage der
sensibilisierung
das ist häufig auch eine frage der
zivilcourage es ist sehr einfach
wegzuschauen und nachher zu sagen wir
haben nicht gewusst
und da finde ich wenn wir jetzt diese
geschichte dieses dunkle kapitel unserer
sozial geschichte aufarbeiten dann
möchte ich zum beispiel dass das auch in
den schulbüchern vorkommt dass auch
unsere kinder wissen was in unserem land
passiert ist dass sich das vorstellen
können das ist ein teil unserer
geschichte ist ist auch ein teil unserer
identität
es ist eben beides und wir dürfen nicht
vergessen man hat ende des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts sehr viel für die heime
gemacht also das ist heime gibt
das war auch etwas gutes private die
kirchen die behörden haben versucht für
kinder die nirgendwo ein zuhause hatten
eine gut eine gute umgebung zu schaffen
und ich denke es wäre jetzt falsch und
ein kurzschluss wenn man sagt heimsheim
ist etwas schlechtes man hat auch sehr
viel gutes gemacht auch heute noch
übrigens aber es gab eben auch die
schattenseiten
es gab die andere seite auch und ich
finde es ist ganz wichtig dass wir
beides sehen
aber natürlich dass wir dich die
schlimmen zeiten dass wir das nicht
ausblenden die wir nicht damals und
heute jetzt direkt vergleichen ich weiß
es in der unterschiedliche schicksale
aber wenn jetzt festgestellt wird diese
behörden sind überfordert das ist eine
überlastung es ist viel zu wenig geld zu
wenig personal da reagiert jetzt da
jemand hatte wir haben in dem in unserem
land ganz gerade zuständigkeiten wo die
kantone zuständig sind oder bund
zuständig ist wo die gemeinden zuständig
sind
ich denke das ist heute geklärt und ich
würde jetzt auch etwas aufpassen wenn
man sagt die behörden sind überlastet
und das gefühl da könnte jetzt niemand
mehr agieren
wir hatten einen großen wechsel leben
von gerade in der vormundschaft zu
dieser professionalisierung das ist für
für die kantonen ein großer schritt ein
großer aufwand aber man muss sich auch
nicht vorstellen dass jetzt das alles
völlig neu ist sondern man hat versucht
überall dort wo man mit einer
professionalisierung menschen gegen
kenntnis haben die die das auch eine
ausbildung dafür haben die wissen wie
man hinschaut die wissen wie man umgeht
man sieht den film oder die lehrerin
wollte etwas gutes tun sie hat sich
eingesetzt für max und am schluss wurde
die situation für die noch schlimmer
man muss heute auch wissen wie man
interveniert wo man interveniert das ist
ganz wichtig dass ein dann von den
einzelnen akteuren akteuren ab ein
weiteres kapitel das mir in diesem
zusammenhang aufgefallen ist den
beobachter von 17 februar diesen jahres
psychiatrische klinik münsterlingen da
wurde an kindern auch an verdient
kindern oder heimkindern wurden versuche
richtige menschen versuche mit
medikamenten gemacht wartet da das
nächste dunkle kapitel aufklärung
das ist ein teil dieses kapitels ja das
ist nicht aus der nächste sondern es ist
bestand da dass menschen das über
menschen verfügt wurde zum teil auch
gegen ihren willen dinge unternommen
worden sind zum beispiel eben mit
kommentar verabreichten medikamente
versuche aber auch eine eine frau die
gezwungen wurde eben mit kind zur
adoption freizugeben
eine frau die unter druck gesetzt wurde
das kind
abzutreiben das ist teil dieser
geschichte
aber das ist durch thomas und gesagt die
ärzteschaft habe bis heute diese
fragwürdige behandelt
behandlungsmethoden nie durchleuchtet
und darf gearbeitet
im gegenteil die psychiatrie blieb ein
tabu und wird nicht hinterfragt das ist
mein bestreben in dem ich diesen prozess
in gang gesetzt habe in dem ich jetzt
die nicht nur die betroffenen sondern
eigentlich die verschiedenen kreise
zusammen genommen habe und mit ihnen
gemeinsam diesen prozess machen möchte
eine aufarbeitung war immer klar es darf
keine tabus geben
jetzt schauen wir ihn jetzt kommt das
auf den tisch und wir haben ja nach dem
gedenkanlass vom letzten april wird
diese situation gedacht haben wo wir das
unrecht auch festgestellt und
festgehalten haben beschlossen dass
jetzt ein prozess eingeleitet wird und
dem alle beteiligt sind sich an einen
runden tisch setzen nicht an einen
eckigen nicht hier die täter und da die
opfer sondern dass sich alle die bereit
sind und gewillt sind gemeinsam dieses
dunkle kapitel anzuschauen dass sie sich
an einen tisch setzen und ich muss ihnen
sagen das ist halt wirklich meinen
größten respekt dass diese menschen
betroffene unmittelbar betroffene aber
auch menschen die behörden vertreten die
organisationen vertreten heime
bauernverband die kirchen sind dabei
dass sie sich an einem runden tisch
setzen und das eben nicht übereinander
sprechen sondern miteinander sprechen
einander zuhören und ich darf ihnen
sagen ich denke das macht unglaublich
viel kraft von allen seiten
wenn man sagt jetzt jetzt hören wir auf
eben übereinander zu sprechen jetzt sind
wir am gleichen tisch regeln miteinander
und gegen und ich habe diesen runden
tisch gebeten empfehlungen zu
formulieren an die politik an die
behörden auch an die organisationen was
ist jetzt zu tun damit dieses dunkle
kapitel dass ich als erstes ziel das nie
mehr wiederholt aber dass wir auch
politisch und überall dort wo es doch
etwas gemacht werden
dass wir dort weiter kommt sitzen an
diesem runden tisch auch mein in diesem
fall abend pharma industrien profitiert
sitzen dafür treten vertreter der pharma
branche
es sind jetzt diese die pharma branche
speziell ist die nicht dabei wir haben
versucht möglichst breit den runden
tisch zu gestalten aber bei den
empfehlungen die jetzt von diesem runden
tisch erarbeitet werden ist sicher wenn
man in speziellen situationen jetzt auch
noch abklären soll um wirklich arbeiten
soll
dann kommt das sicher auch hinzu das ist
noch einmal ist darf dort kein tabu
geben
wichtig ist aber dass das jetzt nicht
ein abschluss ist also man hat nicht
miteinander gesprochen und das war jetzt
gut überhaupt nicht sondern dass wir
sagen jetzt kommen die empfehlungen und
die aufarbeitung das ist ein ganz
wichtiges kapitel und das wird
schmerzhaft sein für viele das wird
nicht einfach sein weil da wird man auch
kritische dinge eben jetzt auch an die
oberfläche bringen
und ich möchte dass dieser prozess
weitergeht dass wir ihn jetzt wirklich
denn auch nicht davor zurückschrecken
das wir sehen was auch gutes gemacht
wurde
das ist mir wichtig zu sagen dass auch
viele leute viel gutes gemacht haben
auch behörden übrigens aber jetzt muss
das auf den tisch kommen
sie haben einem gedenkanlass erwähnt im
letzten jahr am 11
april wir haben einen kurzen ausschnitt
vorbereitet dass der sendung 10 vor 10
über diesen gedenkanlass es ist deshalb
an der zeit dass wir etwas tun was man
ihnen allen
den ehemaligen verdient finden und den
weiteren opfern von fürsorgerischen
zwangsmassnahmen bisher verweigert hat
für das leid das ihnen angetan wurde
bitte ich sie im namen der
landesregierung aufrichtig und von
ganzem herzen um entschuldigung für die
zwangssterilisierten hat heute
bernadette gächter gesprochen
die ostschweizerin wurde als 18 jährige
schwanger und musste auf druck ihrer
pflegeeltern abtreiben gleichzeitig
wurde sie genötigt ihrer sterilisation
zuzustimmen der grund ihre leibliche
mutter war in eine psychiatrische klinik
eingeliefert worden
die beiden frauen galten als erblich
minderwertig ihr erbgut sollte nicht
verbreitet werden das war 1972 noch
heute leitet bernadette gäste darunter
dass sie nie mutter werden konnte ich
will bestimmen was ich mit meinen akten
und mit den akten meiner mutter mache
und nicht wie bisher der staat
ich will in keinem archiv der schweiz
mehr mit aktien hinterlegt sein
ich finde das ist mein gutes recht danke
bundesweite anerkennung für einen
jahrelangen kampf und bernadette gächter
hat gekämpft damit sie gehört wurde
damit die schweiz sicht der dunklen
vergangenheit stellt also ich sehe ihn
wichtige tag und für mich und risk i/o
für gerechtigkeit umkrempeln
endlich klar wenn jetzt erwähnt gesenkt
und erkämpft
und ich habe noch nie etwas passiert die
geschichte der verdingkinder heimkinder
administrativ versorgten und
zwangssterilisierten soll nun restlos
aufgeklärt werden mit einem runden tisch
an dem auch bernadette gestern
teilnehmen will
sie bitten um entschuldigung
ich meine sie haben ja persönlich nichts
getan was es geht ihnen in diesem moment
durch den kopf oder durch die säle
das ist eine entschuldigung im namen der
landesregierung
das ist ein sehr spezieller moment ein
sehr spezieller rugby haben uns im
bundesrat intensiv darüber unterhalten
naja das war thema im bundesrat
verständlich ich habe das im namen der
landesregierung im namen des bundesrates
gemacht und wir waren uns einig dass es
wichtig ist diesen ersten schritt zu
machen um das unrecht ist diesen vielen
menschen angetan wurde
um dieses zu erkennen wir wissen aber
auch dass das nur ein erster schritt ist
eine entschuldigung ist ein anerkennen
und ich denke im moment war wirklich
sehr sehr sehr sehr wichtig für viele
betroffene
gleichzeitig hat jetzt haben die letzten
monate gezeigt das ist kein einfacher
prozess
viele betroffene hatten die hoffnung
dass das jetzt sehr schnell geht das
jetzt sich vieles verändert dass sich
vieles bewegt und sie waren zum teil
auch jetzt wieder enttäuscht über die
behörden sagten den eindruck es geht zu
wenig es geht zu wenig schnell
und deshalb habe ich vorhergesagt diese
kraft dass das braucht an diesem runden
tisch zu bleiben um das auszuhalten dass
es vielleicht nicht so schnell geht
auszuhalten dass man sich austauschen
muss dass es andere sichtweisen gibt
auszuhalten auch dass die betroffenen
sehr unterschiedliche bedürfnisse haben
dass sie für die einen war diese
entschuldigung ganz wichtig andere haben
gesagt hören sie auf darüber zu sprechen
hatte
auch von betroffenen die mir gesagt
haben wegen ihnen ist bei mir alles
wieder aufgebrochen ich habe das
geschafft etwas auch etwas zu vergessen
die bedürfnisse sind sehr
unterschiedlich und ich denke es wird
jetzt eine ganz wichtige aufgabe ist ein
immer wieder zu schauen was sind die
unterschiedlichen bedürfnisse was können
wir tun was macht unsere gesellschaft
und damit wie gehen wir hier weiter und
das ist ein langwieriger und ein
schwieriger prozess und so viele
betroffene waren ja vor allem von den
behörden immer wieder enttäuscht worden
und ihre angst ist dass jetzt auch
wieder enttäuscht werden und ich werde
alles dafür tun dass sie nicht
enttäuscht werden aber ich brauche
natürlich auch ihr verständnis dass ein
prozess eben zeitgleich das ist dass man
traum bleiben muss dass das eben ein
prozess ich den wird gemeinsam gehen
müssen die betroffenen sind ja sehr holz
zum teil
die entschuldigung 2013 kommt die nicht
sehr spät
sie kommt sehr spät aber sie ist
wenigstens gekommen wie erklären sie es
dass das ein so lange gedauert hat
gut es ist nicht so dass man wurde
nichts gemacht hat meine vorgänger
bundesrätin widmer schlumpf hat sich
entschuldigt bei dem die minister
lieferstopp von wenigen die in ein
gefängnis kamen honig straftat ihm
vielleicht weil sie ein uneheliches kind
geboren haben oder man von zu hause
ausgerissen sind jahrelang im gefängnis
zusammen mit straffälligen personen
es gab früher auch immer wieder versuche
dieses thema überhaupt darüber zu
sprechen darüber zu sprechen was ist
eigentlich passiert und das ist
natürlich schon so es ist unangenehm
es ist für viele unangenehm es gibt
diejenigen die das nicht wahrhaben
wollen
es gibt diejenigen die sagen aber mit
uns hat das nichts zu tun
natürlich sagen sie zu recht ich
persönlich muss mich nicht entschuldigen
als person aber ich vertrete die
landesregierung die anerkennt was
können großes unrecht ich gemacht worden
ist in unserem land in unserer
gesellschaft und deshalb ist es ganz
wichtig dass auch diese entschuldigung
erfolgt ist
ich glaube für für viele war das ein
anfang ein anfang jetzt ja der
vielleicht mal etwas gelöst hat
defensivspieler haben wir uns noch mal
gehört bernadette gerechter wir sprechen
von hunderttausenden von menschen im 19
im zwanzigsten jahrhundert gibt es haben
sie eine ahnung wie viele ehemalige
verdingen heimkinder noch leben nein das
wissen wir nicht
das wissen wir nicht wir möchten sich
hier versuchen herauszufinden wir aber
natürlich sehr viele briefe bekommen
zuschriften jetzt leute sich gemeldet
haben weil wir haben gesagt es geht die
arbeit in den runden tisch auch darum zu
überlegen was können wir schnell und sie
haben es gesagt viele menschen sind
jetzt in einem fortgeschrittenen alter
sie möchten nicht warten und die sollen
auch nicht warten müssen
wir haben zusammen mit den kantonen
gesagt wir haben bei den opfer hilfe
stellen jetzt auch die möglichkeit dass
sich menschen eben die von solchen
fürsorgerischen zwangsmassnahmen
betroffen sind dort melden kann
unterstützung bekommen
vechta hat den zugang zu den archiven
talente das ganz wichtiges stellen sie
sich vor über sie steht in einem archiv
etwas was falsch ist was andere über sie
entschieden haben und das steht über sie
und das wird geil weil der eigenen
heiraten eingetragen unehelich geboren
hatte stellen sie sich vor auch wenn sie
eben sieben jahre im gefängnis wagen was
schreiben sie in ihrem curriculum was
streiten sich über dieses mittel und das
ist das bedürfnis ich denke gerade auch
den erstens dass die akten nicht
vernichtet werden dass diese geschichte
erhalten bleibt dass man nicht einfach
darüber hinweg geht und versucht aus zu
löschen was unangenehm ist
das ist ganz wichtig dass wir eben diese
geschichte auch präsent nicht mal
behalten weil sie heute zu wenig präsent
sondern dass wir uns wirklich darum
bemühen wissen zu wollen was war denn
eigentlich und was mich in vielen
briefen sehr berührt ist wie präzise
betroffene menschen erinnerungen haben
sie beschreiben wie die peitsche
ausgesehen hat mit dem sie täglich
geschlagen worden
sie beschreiben wir mit ihm den weg den
sie gemacht haben dem den heimweg wo sie
zu hause geschlagen wurden und dann so
viel gearbeitet haben dass sie die
hausaufgaben nicht machen konnte am
nächsten morgen kommen sie die schuhe
hatten die hausaufgaben nicht gemacht
wurden dort wieder geschlagen
und jemand dem ich beschrieben hat wie
sie jeweils auf dem nachhauseweg im wald
ein paar erdbeeren gepflückt hat weil
sie so hunger hatte und nach allen
gesucht hat grüne äpfel gegessen hat
weil sie so hunger hatte nach er
bauchweh hatte also die erinnerungen
sind häufig ganz präzise und werden
wieder geweckt durch diesen prozess und
werden wieder geweckt werden
niedergeschrieben werden mitgeteilt und
ich denke es ist ganz wichtig dass die
menschen die es wollen nur diejenigen
die es wollen dass sie sich mitteilen
können dass sie aufschreiben können dass
sie erzählen können dass eben jemanden
haben der ihnen zuhört und der sich
interessiert für tanz das ist das
wesentliche
vielleicht man kann dieses unrecht nicht
wiedergutmachen markieren dieses unrecht
nicht annullieren
aber man kann wissen wollen sich
interessieren was ist passiert und
natürlich in dem die gesellschaft
darüber kenntnis hat hat auch ein stück
stigmatisieren dass er auch
stattgefunden hat das denke ich dass
kann man reduzieren und an wen wenden
sich die betroffenen
die betroffenen haben zum teil sich auch
organisiert und organisationen die die
auch ihre interessen vertreten sind auch
an die betroffenen länder um den tisch
der weisen vertreten ja auch zum teil
ihre organisationen
sie wenden sich vielleicht an opferhilfe
stellen
viele haben jetzt geschrieben viele
haben und das hat mich auch sehr beliebt
im hohen alter gesagt dass sie es eben
zum ersten mal dass jemand sagen
stellen sie sich ein leben vor sie haben
eine solche kindheit gehabt sie haben
vielleicht eine familie
sie haben gearbeitet und sie haben nie
mit jemandem darüber gesprochen was man
damit sich herumträgt und das war häufig
aus angst vor stigmatisierung
was du bist ein heimkind warst du bist
ein verdingkind und ich denke unsere
gesellschaft muss das wissen und indem
sie es weiß indem sie weiß was passiert
ist hört das auch auf das hört dass
allmählich auf dass man das noch noch
stigmatisiert stellen sie sich vor die
menschen denen das passiert ist die
fühlen sich noch schuldig dafür dass er
ist ja auch eine mehrheit wurde
es wurde ihnen ein sie wollten
erniedrigt es wurde ihr
selbstbewusstsein ausgelöscht
und das ist eigentlich das was mich am
meisten bewegt man hat hier wirklich die
menschliche würde verletzt
das ist das schlimmste es gibt das
beispiel von servette am ehemaligen
heimkind er hat auch gesprochen bei
diesem gedenkanlass hat selber später in
einem heim als heimleiter gearbeitet bei
seiner pensionierung hat er das erste
mal darüber gesprochen
er sagt aber auch wenn er sich äußert es
ist wichtig dass die opfer
fürsorgerischer zwangsmaßnahmen
ehemalige verdingkinder heimkinder
finanzielle entschädigung sehen
das heißt für die arbeit zb diese
einfach geleistet haben sollen sie
finanziell entschädigt werden der runde
tisch hat einen soforthilfefonds
eingerichtet der ist gedacht für
menschen die eben jetzt betroffen sind
die aber in einer notlage sind da sind
ja nicht alle
der fonds ist mit fünf millionen franken
aus dem lotteriefonds gespeist es kommen
andere beiträgen zu es ist die rede von
sieben bis acht millionen franken wenn
man das umrechnet gibt es vier bis 12000
franken für betroffene die aber jetzt
wirklich sofort hilfe brauchen jetzt
aber unter uns gesagt die in der reichen
schweiz hier ist 12.000 frauen
muss vielleicht folgendes sagen mir war
ganz wichtig ich habe das auch am
gedenkanlass gesagt eine aufarbeitung
beinhaltet zu wissen was passiert ist
eine aufarbeitung beinhaltet aber auch
dass man über finanzielle fragen
sprechen darf und so und das wird an
diesem runden tisch auch gemacht und man
hat an diesem runden tisch darüber
gesprochen was können wir sofort tun und
deshalb ist diese soforthilfe vorgesehen
einfach sofort unbürokratisch die können
sagen die beiträge sind zu klein sie
sind hoch es war die bereitschaft bei
den kantonen hier sofort einen beitrag
zu leisten wir suchen auch weitere
beteiligte die bereit sind hier ganz
unbürokratisch zu helfen der schweizer
bauernverband bauernverband sagt vor
wenigen tagen wir beteiligen uns nicht
wir haben ja diese maßnahmen auch nicht
verfügt gut ich hätte hier unterscheiden
der bauernverband ist auch mit am runden
tisch dabei und hat damit zum ausdruck
gebracht dass sie bereit ist diese
geschichte auch aufzuarbeiten und bereit
ist hinzuschauen und seinen beitrag zu
leisten
jetzt sprechen wir von dieser
soforthilfe ich würde hier jetzt nicht
den stab über jemanden brechen sondern
sagen das ist ein freiwilliger beitrag
und ich freue mich und ich bin sehr
dankbar über alle die hier sich daran
beteiligen wenn ihr über finanzielle
leistungen sprechen dann sprechen wir
aber über eine über eine andere frage
und ich bin froh dass der runde tisch
diese frage jetzt auch sehr fundiert
diskutiert sind sich aber alle bewusst
wenn es eine finanzielle leistungen gibt
dann wird das eine gesetzliche grundlage
bleiben weil dann können wir gebrauchen
dann können wir nicht im bereich
freiwillige beiträge sprechen oder und
ein gesetzlicher prozess ist ein
langwieriger prozess in dem man in
unserem land mehrheiten finden muss im
bundesrat mehrheit im parlament
mehrheiten in der bevölkerung
das ist allen bekannt
es braucht eine gesetzliche grundlage
und deshalb ist runde tisch und ich
denke das ist das erste mal in der
geschichte dass hier eben die
betroffenen verschiedenen organisationen
die behörden auch die wissenschaft
zusammen sind und ich darf ihnen sagen
auch mit meiner politischen erfahrung
wenn es ihnen gelingt gemeinsam
empfehlungen zu formulieren auch an die
politik dann ist die chance
wahrscheinlich so groß wie noch nie dass
man wirklich auch etwas erreichen kann
aber das muss man aushalten das ist ein
prozess ist dass es mehrheiten braucht
das es überzeugungsarbeit gebraucht und
meine meine ganze hoffnung ist liegt
wirklich darin dass alle die hier dabei
sind das jetzt auch dabei bleiben und
dass sie bereit sind auch eben diese
diese dauer auszuhalten dass sie bereit
sind dann auch ja dass die fragen werden
kommen unangenehme tatsachen werden auf
dem tisch liegen und dass sie auch
bereit sind das parlament dafür zu
gewinnen und zu überzeugen dass weitere
schritte nötig sind ich werde sie dabei
unterstützen
aber es braucht eben ein gemeinsames
vorgehen und das ist in früheren zeiten
nie gelungen und deshalb sind auch
frühere versuche immer gescheitert weil
es nicht einen gemeinsamen anlauf gab es
ist ein sehr sensibler prozess das wird
spürbar sehr sehr sensibel
ich muss jetzt doch noch etwas beharren
ein gesetzesprozess zwei bis drei jahre
es gibt jetzt ein gesetz für
administrativ versorgte da drin ist von
aufarbeitung die rede von aber nicht von
geld geld ist explizit ausgeschlossen
das wäre ja dann bei den verdienen und
heimkindern auch so das parlament hat
beschlossen dass man dieses gesetz für
die administrativ versorgten jetzt
gemacht und es hat festgehalten dass es
jetzt in diesem gesetz weil das ja nur
einen teil der betroffenen betrifft
jetzt die frage auffällige finanzielle
leistungen nicht hier in diesem
speziellen gesetz regeln will das
parlament aber gewusst dass diese
menschen jetzt älter aber man ist sich
bewusst dass diese finanzielle fragen
nicht für eine gruppe von betroffenen
geregelt werden kann sondern dass man
hier wirklich wenn man eine andere
lösung arbeitet
dass man sich dann wirklich und alle
wenden muss und das parlament und ich
bin sehr froh hat explizit gesagt dieser
entscheid jetzt in diesem gesetz für
eine gruppe von betroffenen finanziellen
leistungen nicht zu regen ist nicht eine
aussage da wir wollen davon nichts
wissen
aber man hielt allfällig fragen in diese
richtung dann in einem prozess behandeln
und auch beantworten wenn es dann
wirklich um alle betroffenen von
physikalischen zwangsmaßnahmen geht das
heißt ein solidaritätsfonds dann
wirklich alle die zu unrecht irgendwo
versorgt und weggesperrt wurden was die
finanziell entschädigt werden das ist
noch nicht vom tisch
ich möchte diese antwort nicht vorweg
nehmen weil ich habe den trug den runden
tisch eingesetzt mit dem auftrag macht
empfehlungen zum beispiel an die politik
zum beispiel an die behörden an die
kantone an die heime an die kirchen also
der runde tisch kann sich auch an
verschiedene stellen wenden und nicht
nur an den bund oder nicht nur an den
bundesrat
und ich möchte wirklich jetzt diesen
prozess auch nicht durchbrechen und uns
selber etwas vorwegnehmen weil ich denke
das muss am runden tisch diskutiert
werden und ich hoffe dass sie sich
finden gemeinsam empfehlungen zu machen
die dann auch von allen mitgetragen
werden
wie groß ist dieser runde tisch wie
viele sitzen da ja das sind die
verschiedenen betroffenen organisationen
zum teil auch direkt betroffene menschen
dabei geben wirklich auch und ich glaube
es ist wichtig zu sagen neben den
verdient kindern wir haben ist jetzt
gehört zwangssterilisationen
zwangskastration zwangsadoptionen sind
wirklich breit dabei pflegekinder
heimkinder dann sind die verschiedenen
behörden dabei die kantone die städte
die gemeinden dann ist der bauernverband
dabei die kirchen
sie ist aber auch die wissenschaft dabei
sind historiker dabei und ich denke
diese runde tisch sichert eigentlich
sind nicht alle einfach mit dabei aber
es ist wirklich eine breite es ist es
ist breit abgestützt und deshalb dauert
es auch diese prozesse etwas aber ich
finde sie haben in dieser kurzen zeit
zeit im letzten april
bereits große schritte gemacht indem man
ihnen gezeigt hat wir wollen und sie
haben vorgesehen dass sie bis zum
nächsten sommer empfehlungen versuchen
zu formulieren und zu verabschieden sind
sie da persönlich dabei oder delegieren
sie wird das auf höchster ebene
verhandelt wer ist dabei ich habe am
gedenkanlass seinen delegierten werden
an das war der alt ständerat
die stadt wird die als delegierte diesen
prozess eingeleitet hat und auch um den
tisch präsent war ich danke es war
wichtig dass das jemand ist die zwar
eingesetzt wurde vom bund aber der eben
ansprechpartner von allen ist und auch
in dem sich unparteiisch ist der
stadtteil hat sehr viel geleistet hat
wirklich die leute zusammengebracht und
diesen prozess in gang gebracht und dann
hatten wir dann abgelöst in der runde
tisch in eine phase kaum wo wirklich
dann jetzt auch die juristischen fragen
zum teil auch im vordergrund steht und
jetzt diese runde tisch geleitet vom
stellvertretenden direktor des
bundesamtes für justiz ich war immer
dabei
ich denke es ist aber wichtig dass man
an diesem runden tisch auch nicht im
präsenz der bundesregierung das
bespricht sondern dass man wirklich
versucht hier jetzt an diesen lösungen
zu arbeiten aber ich verfolge die arbeit
mit allergrößtem interesse und auch mit
größtem respekt ich finde da haben
menschen auch eine verantwortung
übernommen
sie haben gesagt ich bin bereit
hinzugehen sie haben den kirchen
tabellen besitzen auch an diesem runden
tisch wir haben jetzt mehrere beispiele
gesehen und gehört der pfarrer im film
der verdingbub wir könnten viele fälle
aus diesem buch aus anderen
schilderungen von missbrauch von
sexuellen missbrauch in kirchlichen
institutionen schildern wie nehmen sie
die rolle der kirchen war diese
missbräuche das gab es das wissen die
leute
und es gab aber auch kirchenvertreter
die ganz gute arbeit geleistet haben die
sich wirklich für die kinder eingesetzt
haben und das ist vielleicht so
schwierig manchmal zu ertragen dass es
eben beides gab dass man anerkennt auch
bei den kirchen dass es leute gab die
wirklich viel gutes gemacht haben
aber das ist ganz schlimme sachen gab es
gab wirklich viele situationen von
sexueller ausbeutung von physischer
psychischer gewalt nicht nur bei den
kirchen sondern wie gesagt auch in
wenigen institutionen und die geschichte
aufarbeiten heißt dass man beides
anschaut
bevor man also das bedürfnis zu urteilen
das bedürfnis eine schuldige zu benennen
und eine aufarbeitung heißt man beim an
arbeit beides auf abend natürlich für
eine gesellschaft ist es immer einfacher
die schönen seiten aufzuarbeiten und die
schwierigen zeiten aufzuarbeiten das ist
für eine gesellschaft immer schwierig
und ich bin überzeugt dass eine
gesellschaft aber letztlich auch nur
vorwärts kommen kann sich entwickeln
kann und reden fehlen nicht mehr machen
kann wenn sie hier sind schalten wir
haben in unserer bundesverfassung in der
präambel einen ganz wichtigen satz oder
eine gesellschaft ist nur so stark wie
auch ihre schwächsten wie sie mit ihren
schwächsten umgeht
eine gesellschaft ist nur so gut wie
auch den umgang mit den schwächsten ist
und deshalb heißt das wenn wir uns jetzt
mit der situation wirklich der
schwächsten denen unrecht getan wurde
wenn die situation jetzt anschauen und
wissen und wissen wollen was passiert
ist dann macht das anschluss auch unsere
gesellschaft stark oder stark und
deshalb glaube ich spüre dass auch es
gibt einen willen auch jetzt in der
bevölkerung wir wollen das wissen wir
können es zum teil zwar fast nicht
glauben aber wir wollen wissen was
geschehen ist
ich erlebe sie sehr nahe an diesem thema
verdient kinder
ehemalige heimkinder all die schicksale
die sie erwähnt haben womit hat das zu
tun können sie persönlich solche
menschen dieses erlebt haben ja
inzwischen zeit kenne ich kenne ich
solche menschen ist habe ich ein
grundbedürfnis habe das haben
ich hoffe das haben alle menschen das
wenn die menschliche würde verletzt wird
dann rebelliert alles in mir dann geht
das nicht und ich denke aus
justizministerin aber auch als
bundesräten aber auch als mensch
wenn es hier eine möglichkeit gibt etwas
zu verhindern wenn es eine möglichkeit
gibt gerade kindern die ihn am meisten
ausgeliefert sind oder erwachsenen oder
auch der gesellschaft zu helfen dass wir
sagen ja was können wir denn tun wie
können die besser hinschauen wie können
wir selber einen beitrag leisten und ich
denke alle auch die heute lebenden
können einen beitrag leisten indem sie
sich interessieren indem sie ihren
kindern vielleicht erzählen sie haben
das buch erwähnt es gibt viele es gibt
auch viele betroffene die ihre
lebensgeschichte aufgeschrieben haben
ein solches buch zu lesen einen film zu
schauen sich betroffen lassen zu machen
das ist ganz wichtig und ich möchte auch
etwas von dem weitergeben weil es mich
selber wirklich auch betroffen macht sie
haben bereits von blinden flecken
gesprochen sie haben den menschenhandel
erwähnt ist auch interessant zu
überlegen wo gibt es in unserer
gesellschaft heute blinde flecken gibt
es weiter
wo wir wegschauen ja meistens ist ja das
problem bei den blinden flecken dass man
sie erst im nachhinein erkennt sonst
werden sie nicht blind
und blinde flecken zu erkennen ist denke
ich einerseits ein bemühen einfach also
die augen offen halten
aber es ist natürlich eine frage die wir
uns heute schon auch immer wieder
stellen und die ich mir auch persönlich
stelle wenn wir vielleicht in zehn 20
und 30 jahren zurückschauen und schauen
was wir heute gemacht haben dann ist die
frage hatten wir genug gemacht haben wir
hingeschaut haben wir uns auch bemüht
die sage ihnen vielleicht ein ganz ein
anderes beispiel aus einem völlig
anderen bereich ich war kürzlich in
tunesien und dort hat man jetzt eine
neue verfassung nach dem arabischen
frühling
ich erzähle ihnen das weil ich habe dort
wieder einmal gespürt was es heißt da
hatten verschiedenste kräfte mussten
kompromisse eingehen mussten sich
bemühen auf die anderen zuzugehen und
sie haben nichts gemacht und sie haben
heute eine verfassung natürlich der weg
ist noch weit aber ich an eine
verfassung wo man gemerkt hat sie haben
die gewissens und religionsfreiheit
haben die chancengleichheit für die
geschlechter
ich erwähne das hier weil ich denke auch
in dieser geschichte werden die menschen
kommen wir nur weiter wenn alle bemüht
sind auch einen schritt aufeinander zu
zu tun wenn alle bereit sind hinzuhören
und sage ich ich interessiere mich für
seine sicht der dinge ist interessiert
mich und kompromisse eingehen ist etwas
was viel kraft braucht ich hoffe dass
wir diese kraft auch immer politisch
wieder aufbringen
auch um zb diesen menschen gerecht
werden zu können
da wird es kräfte brauchen um
aufeinander zuzugehen
sie werden den arabischen frühling das
ist eine große bewegung wenn man in die
welt hinaus schaut aus der kleinen
schweiz die migration ist ein riesiges
thema auch in der literatur
es boomt es tut sich etwas aber die
menschen die da unterwegs sind tun wir
genug für flüchtlinge
also ich denke wir könnten alle immer
mehr tun
wir müssen aber aufpassen dass vor
lauter gefühl wir könnten mehr tun wir
am schluss nicht das tun was möglich ist
und was menschenmöglich ist und was auch
politisch möglich ist ich spüre manchmal
beim bemühen auch jetzt zum beispiel im
umgang mit mit diesem dunklen kapitel
unserer geschichte dass man sagt das ist
so schlimm dass dann am schlussmann fast
gelähmt ist weil es wenn man eben
unrecht nicht wieder ungeschehen machen
kann und sie haben jetzt die flüchtlinge
wenn man das elend auf diese welt ist so
gigantisch dass aus einem aufnehmen kann
und das darf nicht passieren und meine
feste überzeugung ist und auch mein
engagement ist dass selbst wenn
vielleicht das unrecht so gigantisch ist
dass wir uns dafür nicht lähmen lassen
dürfen sondern dass wir wege suchen und
das ist vielleicht jetzt ihr diese runde
tisch und in einem anderen bereich ist
es die internationale zusammenarbeit
wenn es um flüchtlinge geht wenn
menschen auf der flucht sind
dass wir wege suchen was wir tun können
was wir gemeinsam tun können aber was
ich erwähnt habe mit den kompromissen
das ist natürlich nur möglich wenn man
es schafft immer wieder aufeinander
zuzugehen und diese kraft die müssen wir
immer wieder aufbringen
die müssen wir politisch immer wieder
aufbringen und die müssen wir aber auch
in der gesellschaft immer wieder
aufbringen
das heißt jetzt bei meiner frage das
bemühen hinzuschauen bedeutet lösungen
für flüchtlinge sie hier bei uns
aufzunehmen aber auch dort wo sie
herkommen die verhältnisse zu verlusten
zu verhindern so dass die integration
gar nicht so stark wird das ist etwas
was zwingend ist also das was wir sagen
was können wir dazu beitragen
ganz wichtig ist auch die hilfe vor ort
menschen wollen häufig nicht einfach
möglichst weit weg von zuhause sie
möchten eigentlich bei sich bleiben aber
sie können nicht sie sind verfolgt an
leib und leben die sind in einer
kriegssituation denken wir nur einen
moment dann an syrien weil das
vielleicht am präsentesten ins
70 prozent in den flüchtlingslagern rund
um syrien sind frauen und kinder
das müssen wir präsent halten und ihnen
müssen wir auch vor ort helfen aber es
gibt auch menschen die fliehen müssen
die weiterfliegen
und da denke ich da haben wir eine große
verantwortung aber auch hier
wir können das nur gemeinsam tun wir
können es gemeinsam zum beispiel mit den
europäischen staaten tun mit denen
wieder auch ein gemeinsames asylsystem
haben wir können das gemeinsam tun mit
den ländern wo die eben unmittelbar
betroffen sind zum beispiel ich sage
jetzt mit den ländern rundung syrien das
können wir nur gemeinsam
wir sind ausgegangen von einem dunklen
kapitel der jüngeren schweizer
sozialgeschichte wir sind in der
gegenwart mit einem blick über unsere
landesgrenzen aus gelandet und hier
danke ich bank ganz herzlich für das
gespräch hat bundesrätin sommaruga
ich danke
[Musik]
dieses gespräch können sie nochmal sehen
auf unserer website
weitere informationen über heim und
verdingkinder finden sie auf unserer
kultur plattform
er ist gegen die frauenquote und gegen
einen allzu großzügigen wohlfahrtsstaat
und er ist für traditionelle
familienstrukturen norbert bolz katja
gentinetta hat den streitbaren denker
eingeladen das gespräch mit ihm sehen
sie nächsten sonntag
jetzt aber kommen wir zur kunst der
regisseur michael haneke keiner seziert
wie er die menschlichen abgründe ein
filmporträt im jahr eins nach dem oscar